Lauren thank you for seeing us and
Jordan thank you for agreeing to this I
know this is a bit of a shock
Jordan is engaged what is the name of
your intended Emma Emma you rang a woman
[Laughter]
a little bit more about em on how you
how you met her I met Emma in a CVS
drugstore I don't remember what I was
buying
was it a male self grooming utensils no
product I use is not sold at CVS what
product is that the norelco body groom
using a rel cool body groom yeah you use
it every day
no and what do you what areas do you
tend to with them
you can speak openly here of course as I
hope this is a safe space for both of
you
yes you could trim hair on almost
anywhere in your body you get to build a
mixin painlessly crannies in fact the
new model the BG 2038 has the advantage
of this all true what you're saying
you're not making this up what's it
called to be the BG 2038 why do you know
the model number of your body replaced
the 20/20 written unfortunately had a
nickel metal hydride battery I would
take 8 hours to charge it was very
important that you don't over charge it
otherwise it decreases battery life tell
me how you actually met him that's all I
really want to know well we met walking
into CBS I don't want to judge and I
know this is not a judging space but
this is a shitty story about how they
met and that's without judgment I think
you're right you're disappointed in him
mama I want to smash his face I'm gonna
say you're angry yeah
hitting his face - it's like humbles
like a mask and then you see the
circuits the name and if you feel - he's
a robot the concern that you're not
super emotional and you seem to have a
bit of a wall up I'm a deeply emotional
man deeply emotional man doesn't say
that I'm a deeply emotional
I had deep feelings and deep thoughts I
could be moved to tears by warm sunlight
on my face
wait warm sunlight on your face moves
you to tears that's just the eye being
irritated but if it moves you to tears
as you show up at CVS for the new
groomer and the Shelf is empty
[Applause]
maybe we could try doing a little bit of
a roleplay maybe I could play Emma for
maybe Emma and we'll just and and and
we'll talk and we'll see what those
let's try that I don't like air
conditioning and I likes air
conditioning often we have disagreements
about air conditioning we don't have
information it's off it's over it's 110
degrees in the valley why can't we have
air conditioning
so Conan as Emma what I want you to do
right now is try to identify the feeling
hot we're just staring at me
you're a monster monster I want air
conditioning and you will not let me
have air conditioning and you just stare
at me like that you don't say anything
then you go in that closet
I make your buttons being pushed are you
talking in an alien voice who are you
talking to you don't seem human to me
we're conditioning
this is something yeah and when your
partner breaks down crying first thing
you do is you don't stare at them you
just fell out of the book American
Psycho and you move towards them and you
put your foot you shouldn't put your
arms around me and comforted me that's
what we women respond to in that moment
are you cold and distant and vague like
this at work is this how you behave at
work is this why no one at work wants to
hang out with you you're always alone is
this how you treat coning do cheat code
like this with this sort of cold
detachment
you shouldn't he's brilliant brilliant
comic mine
[Applause]
you always smell like perfume man it's
not right unfortunately I think in
today's society and least in Western
society we've learned to cover up our
natural smell in East Africa you'll
notice that because deodorant is not
used
thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I think you should be Emma for a second
and I will be Jordan and I will show you
why then I will show you what it's like
what are you usually doing in the
kitchen cooking okay alright and you
make the pasta yourself sometimes I use
double zero flour five extra large eggs
- I'm a double zero flour is the same
flour as all purpose however 50 percent
round all-purpose flour would support
surprise with cake flour sorry why did
you ask him just what is he doing in the
kitchen let's take it from the top and
go I would like to turn on the air
conditioning why I'm hot it's humid you
should experience the climate as it is
meant to be experienced for you to have
a different temperature human comfort
human what is this human you humans I
mean her we humans hold on the female
unit is suspicious of me what should I
do
[Music]
thank you lord we haven't made plans yet
[Applause]
what makes me happy it's to make you
happy when you care about someone what
gives you joy I care about someone when
I care about when I care about someone
[Laughter]
what his pleasure is for me to give you
I thought we made a real breakthrough
there that was spent you know what that
was fantastic
group hug what do we do at the end of a
session usually it's great yes yes
product on his forehead is a real person
you